empleados con pleno derecho a acogerse a
la legislación laboral el tribunal
supremo de reino unido confirmó un fallo
de cortes inferiores que data del 2016
un duro golpe para la plataforma uber
que deberá considerar a sus conductores
no como trabajadores autónomos sino como
empleados con derechos básicos como
vacaciones pagadas y descansos
la legislación pretende dar ciertas
protecciones a los individuos
vulnerables que tienen poca o ninguna
voz sobre su salario y condiciones de
trabajo porque están en una posición
subordinada y dependiente en relación
con una persona u organización que
ejerce control sobre su trabajo
los jueces del tribunal supremo
rechazaron por unanimidad del recurso de
uber una decisión que amenaza el modelo
de negocio de la empresa californiana y
que podría tener consecuencias más
amplias para la llamada economía
colaborativa por parte de los
demandantes es un alivio tras una larga
batalla legal imagina poder tomarte un
día libre para hacer algo con tus hijos
en el colegio o si no te encuentras bien
lo que todavía no tenemos es acceso a la
paga por enfermedad oa la protección
contra el despido improcedente son cosas
por las que todavía tendremos que seguir
luchando pero esto es un gran paso
adelante
la empresa cuenta con unos 65 mil
conductores activos en el reino unido-
este viernes las acciones de uber
bajaron un 3% en las operaciones previas
a la comercialización en la bolsa de
nueva york